the prodigy was directed by Nicholas
McCarthy and stars Taylor Schilling as a
mother deeply concerned about her son's
misconduct he's speaking foreign
languages in his sleep odd things are
happening around him and she begins to
worry about what could be going on in
his head the implications of this are
they supernatural or is it something
else
Nicholas McCarthy directed the pack to
film i think is pretty overlooked they'd
never seen it check it out but i was
interested to see what he would do with
a bigger budget and some named stars
like Taylor Schilling and Colm Feore who
shows up in this movie as a psychiatrist
such a brilliant actor if you've never
seen a storm of the century I talk about
it often please fucking watch that it's
so damn good but it is an early year
horror release and sometimes that
doesn't always bode very well for the
quality of the film but not always it's
not always the way it is I mean split
came out in January so you never know
and I was pleasantly surprised with this
film it's by no means the next classic
of this genre but it is much better than
the trailers led me to believe much of
that is because of Nicholas McCarthy he
does some really great things here
there's some very atmospheric scenes the
opening is really chilling actually not
just because it takes place in Ohio but
because I was pretty much glued to the
screen from the first shot I love when a
director lets you know from the first
shot that they give a shit and I was
interested after that a lot of directors
they don't really try that much with
their opening shots they just expect you
to be interested all of a sudden but
when a director is able to just grab you
from that first image that at least
maintains your interest even if the
scene isn't as good as that first image
and I think the first shot is damn good
but it also has a nice reversal of what
we're used to seeing in a film about an
evil kid usually it's a possession or
something along those lines but this
movie takes a different route and it
tells a story that I wasn't expecting
because again I didn't really know that
much about the film going in I had only
seen a teaser trailer and so I expected
just about anything and so I won't ruin
it for you if you don't know the
direction the film takes Taylor
Schilling is also very good here she
gives a very real performance and
son miles played by Jackson Robert Scott
in certain scenes he's excellent and in
others he's not quite as good but it's
certainly not a bad performance and and
his character is is integral to this
film working and so casting the right
child actor was obviously something on
their minds and they did a pretty good
job he's good in the film and I could
see him doing other things but there's
there are a few scenes that were just a
little off but for the most part
especially in some of the darker scenes
he's damn good the best jump scares
usually involve misdirection it's like a
magician who's really good with sleight
of hand and Nicholas McCarthy is good
with jump scares and some of them did
legitimately get me and it wasn't just
because of the sound effect it was
because it was rather unnerving and
there are sequences in the film like
that this is not a perfect film though
there are some major issues I have with
it and most of them are pacing after the
initial mystery sets up and she begins
to do her investigation into what could
be happening to her son some scenes are
just kind of boring but there are some
incredible scenes one of the best being
with a psychiatrist and the boy and the
boy is manipulating this conversation
and you realize that something really
bad could happen if it goes the way it
should but we know it's not going to and
that scene was great there are really
good sequences like that peppered
throughout some rather mediocre ones the
ending to is I don't want to say it's
disappointing it is just kind of
needlessly dark and depressing and it
feels like certain things just happen
for the purpose of that ending that kind
of I don't wanna get into spoilers it's
hard to see exactly what happens happen
in the way it does unless they really
wanted it to end the way it ends I'm
fine with a dark ending in horror I mean
my favorite movie of last year was
hereditary so obviously it just feels
like the emotion wasn't quite as earned
as it could have been like they were
setting up an ending that is even darker
than the one we actually get but it's
almost like they were kind of afraid to
do that and so we got this sort of bait
and switch maybe there's going to be a
sequel ending which disappointed me but
still for the majority of the runtime
was impressed with the craft on display
and I think this is much better than
most early year horror films I'm gonna
give the prodigy a b-minus guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]